je hais notre époque c'est de la merde
qu'est 10 à amanda lear non ça pourrait
mais pourquoi c'est quoi cette fois
c'est quoi ça c'est votre modèle à
l'hélice et
c'est moi d'ailleurs saddam une femme
enceinte de limbo et non pas question
alors on n'est pas dans les grosses
têtes mais c'est vrai que si je
reconnais le jeu comme ça gêne c'est un
politique et voir alors non c'est un
homme monte vous avez peut-être vivant
j'ai fait un homme vivant on peut poser
des questions et jean marie bigard non
non non mais vivant mais il commença à
on a fêté son anniversaire ah bah oui on
s'est tous les anniversaires
et leurs pilotes parce qu'il a déclaré
il a déclaré chez pascal praud sûr
at-elle dit à une époque aussi des
autographes je l ai selphy je hais cette
époque ma génération regrette sa
jeunesse c'était la fête c'est de la
merde cette époque et on peut plus fumer
rézé c'est bien lui positif bref voilà
c'est le redoux alors qu'est ce que vous
en pensez qu est ce que vous pensez des
policiers je sais que tu as une théorie
là-dessus que j'adore sur le c'était
mieux avant maintenant mais c'est le
principe de la vieillesse c'était mieux
avant mon père disait ça tous les son
père disait ça aussi ces actions
montrent c'était mieux avant remonte au
moyen-age voilà mais c'est un principe
physiologique qui fait que quand on
vieillit on ne se sont plus à l'aise
dans l'époque on vit et du coup ça nous
facilite le passage vers l'au delà vers
la mort les moins triste de mourir
ce sans décalage on aime plus des
abysses est vrai qu est ce que tu fous
en boîte à 60 ans doit
jeûner mais brûlé plus de big show
différence entre c'était mieux avant et
cette époque elle la mère enfin je veux
dire c'est vous trouvez un bon café il
fait vous trouvez qu'il fait vieux con
vous adorer ce qu'ils n'ont jeu puis ça
fait vieux qu'on en fait savoir des gens
qui le suivent à notre époque donc ya
pas à critiquer mieux avant ok je
préférais l'époque dans laquelle moi
j'ai performer ok mais c'est de la merde
dans ce cas là dieu alain delon dit la
même chose à la de l'eau a dit aussi
cette époque c'est l'arrière pas du camp
il ya tout ce que cette génération il
disait ça du tout on va écouter du
chemin les gens de leur coopération
parce qu'il ya plein de jeux il ya plein
de jeunes qui dit ça aussi ce qu'ils
reprochent singulièrement c'est que
comme il est extrêmement connue il
déteste quand inconnu et j'imagine que
toi tu connais ça un peu c'est enfin
celle fille il se trouvait que les
narines comme ça ils détestent la
scénographe de juillet mais conduire il
aimait fumée ccc ces détails là mais
sinon il ya plein de gens qui disent
influencés il est dans son rôle en
disant ça je l'avais
il a toujours condamné la police de la
pensée la bien-pensance convient peut
aujourd'hui c'est ça qu'il extrait avant
tout
si l'époque et c'est de la merde ou si
michel sardou a raison de dire c'est un
ami sincère de ce qu'on en pense que
c'est génial le vieil oncle vient donc à
la maison c'est sa fête de famille qui
veut toujours des trucs un peu horrible
il aime bien cultiver ce truc là et la
tête de tony curtis est vieux
disait déjà il ya 20 ans mais willy à 30
ans il a déjà été heureux ça me laisse
donc les époques qu'on passe à quelqu'un
d'autre mais ken pour que vous
l'écoutiez parce que michel sardou cette
heure nous voilà presque il ya dix
mois beaucoup de gens là on a
l'impression que vous aimez pas trop
notre époque d'aujourd'hui quand on
jette ça va oui mais pas changer ça
veut dire c'est plus rien le plupart de
leurs huit ont pu voir en plus fumer on
peut plus voyez ce que je veux dire on
peut ne peut plus rien
moi j'adore cette série j'adore me cette
voie là bas je suis moi aussi je pense
que c'était mieux avant
tubize acclamant chantant glissé je peux
te dire